T
GOVERNMENT OF SOUTH AFRICA AND
THERE MAY BE LESSONS FOR THE
WORLD AND WHAT'S HAPPENING
THERE.
ONE IS ONE CHAOS STRIKES, YOU'RE
ON YOUR OWN.
OUR NEW DOCUMENTARY SERIES,
TUCKER CARLSON ORIGINALS, THE
NEW EPISODE TAKES A LOOK AT HOW
AMERICANS HAVE SURVIVED PERIODS
OF ANARCHY.
IT'S FASCINATING, A FASCINATING
PIECE OF FILM, YOU CAN WATCH IT
ON FOXNation.com RIGHT NOW.
WE'VE BEEN WONDERING FOR A WHILE
HOW VOTER IDENTIFICATION IS
RACIST.
ALL THE POLLS SHOW THAT
AMERICANS OF ALL COLORS THINK
YOU OUGHT TO BE REQUIRED TO SHOW
I.D., PROVE YOU ARE YOU, WHEN
YOU VOTE.
IF MOLLY HARRIS SAID MANY TIMES
IT'S RACIST AND ON FRIDAY SHE
ACTUALLY SPELLED OUT HOW IT IS.
WATCH.
>> IS AGREEING TO VOTER I.D. ONE
OF THOSE COMPROMISES?
>> I DON'T THINK WE SHOULD
UNDERESTIMATE WHAT THAT COULD
MEAN.
BECAUSE IN SOME PEOPLE'S MINDS,
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TO XEROX OR
PHOTOCOPY YOUR I.D. TO SEND IT
INTO PROVE THAT YOU ARE WHO YOU
ARE.
THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE,
ESPECIALLY PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN
RURAL COMMUNITY, THERE'S NO
KINKO'S, THERE'S NO OFFICEMAX
NEAR THEM.
PEOPLE HAVE TO UNDERSTAND WHEN
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT VOTER I.D.
LAWS, BE CLEAR ABOUT WHO YOU
HAVE IN MIND AND WHAT WOULD BE
REQUIRED OF THEM TO PROVE WHO
THEY ARE.
OF COURSE PEOPLE HAVE TO PROVE
WHO THEY ARE.
BUT NOT IN A WAY THAT MAKES IT A
MOST IMPOSSIBLE FOR THEM TO
PROVE WHO THEY ARE.
>> Tucker: [LAUGHS]
IN RURAL AREAS, TO WHICH I'VE
NEVER BEEN, THEY CAN'T GET TO
KINKO'S.
IS THERE ANY KINKO'S ANYWHERE?
DOES KINKO'S EVEN EXIST?
TAMMY BRUCE KEEPS TRACK OF
AMERICA'S RETAIL LANDSCAPE, THE
HOST OF ANOTHER SHOW YOU SHOULD
WATCH ON FOX NATION, AND WE ARE
HAPPY TO HAVE HER JOIN US
TONIGHT.
SO LET'S SAY YOU LIVE IN A RURAL
AREA FROM A PLACE THAT
KAMALA HARRIS HAS NEVER BEEN,
HOW HARD IS IT TO GET TO A
KINKO'S RIGHT NOW WOULD YOU SAY?
>> I'LL TELL YOU.
KAMALA MAY KNOW THIS BEST
BECAUSE SHE CAN'T FIND HER JOB.
RIGHT?
SHE HAS NO IDEA WHERE THAT IS.
SHE DOESN'T KNOW WHAT IT
ENTAILS, SHE DOESN'T KNOW WHAT
TO DO WITH IT.
SHE CAN'T DO DIPLOMACY, SHE
DOESN'T KNOW HOW TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS.
SO IT'S KAMALA HARRIS WHO
DOESN'T UNDERSTAND WHERE THINGS
ARE.
THE FACT IS, OF COURSE, WE CAN
JOKE ABOUT HARRIS THAT SHE
DOESN'T CLEARLY KNOW AMERICA AT
ALL.
I WOULD ARGUE RURAL AMERICA CAN
OF COURSE -- THEY ARE RUNNING
BUSINESSES, THEY RUN FARMS, THEY
FEED THE WORLD.
JUST LIKE IN URBAN AREAS THERE
MAY BE SOME ECONOMIC PROBLEMS,
PEOPLE OF ALL DIFFERENT COLORS,
BUT THE QUESTION HERE IS I'M A
BESIDES THE INSULT OF IT, IS WHY
ARE THE DEMOCRATS SO DESPERATE
TO MAKE CHEATING EASIER?
THIS IS WHAT'S AMAZING.
AND THE MONMOUTH POLE, YOU
MENTIONED THE POLLING LAST
MONTH.
68% -- 62% OF DEMOCRATS WANT
VOTER I.D., 87% OF INDEPENDENTS
AND 91% OF THE G.O.P.
NO ONE WANTS WHAT THEY ARE
SAYING AND YET THEY ARE SO
DESPERATE NOW -- THEY ARE SAYING
YOU CAN'T DO IT -- RURAL
PEOPLE -- TRUMP VOTERS WERE TOLD
THEY ARE VACCINE RESISTORS, THEY
INVADED -- INSURRECTION IN
JANUARY, SO THEIR COMP LOOKING
TO PEOPLE BUT THEY'VE DONE ALL
OF THIS WITHOUT AN OFFICEMAX.
I DON'T KNOW HOW THEY COULD BE
CAPABLE OF DOING ALL OF THAT,
BUT I THINK THAT THIS IS A SIGN
OF THE DEMOCRATS NOW GRASPING AT
STRAWS TO TRY TO KEEP PEOPLE
FROM BEING ABLE TO KNOW THEIR
VOTE IS SAFE.
IT'S A PROBLEM.
>> Tucker: YEAH, IF YOU'RE NOT
FOR VOTER I.D., WE CAN ASSUME
SINISTER INT